buck saxon is a radio host he hosts clay
buck and he says this he's lived in new
york for the last i don't know 20 30
years every night outside my new york
city apartment it sounds like mad max on
the streets as biker gangs atv mobs and
drag racers with cars sounding like f-18
fighter jets tear through times square
and packs it's a loud reminder of new
york city's rampant lawlessness and the
mayor's incompetence i see this i
identify with it you know i'm a new
yorker i love the city um but there's a
lot of problems going on in new york
city right now
yeah can we keep that tweet up for a
second
is he saying that he lives in times
square no he i don't know where he lives
actually but he he lives close enough
to hear it sounds like mad max in the
street yeah he lives close to the time
square area
so he could be what the [ __ ] are you
doing living near times square a lot of
people you can hear times square you
live in 54th and 8th you can hear all
the trouble going on okay because times
square is what 40th and yeah but you can
hear all that stuff okay and [ __ ] goes
down times square believe me because
times square is an absolute chaos though
it's a [ __ ] yeah yeah so so go live
on the upper east side or go live in
america it's all bad i got friends on
the upper east side right now that are
living in they're really really worried
about the crime is real bad and we talk
a lot about the show about crime about
what's going on with the da's there
where you have you know criminals that
you know somebody commits a crime and
they roam free the next day no bail and
then you've got people now in new york
city i know if you saw that story about
the guy who owns the bodega who
committed you know he was acting in
self-defense and ultimately wound up in
rikers island on a 250 000 bail because
he stabbed someone who was stabbing him
ridiculous going on in new york so i'm
curious though because you were in you
were in new york city
you're from florida from miami yeah so
when you go to a place tonight what was
your experience there as someone
traveling now granted okay you don't
live there every day you're experiencing
a taste of it how did you feel being in
new york and how how did it feel
different new york versus miami the vibe
the energy how populated was it
what were you thinking and feeling when
you went over well number one i go to
new york every summer i haven't been
back since covid so i'll say that i
haven't been since 2020 21
now 2022 so i haven't been in
technically
three summers whatever but i've gone
every year since
2010 when uh
you know
kim and chris were doing their whole
thing to circle back back to camp that's
why i mean i've been going so i love new
york
um
i've heard a lot obviously since i've i
can't tell you how many friends have
moved out of new york down to south
florida during the pandemic
um
but i ran all over the streets of new
york shout out to neil because he was
following me because i was filming
all throughout new york you guys i saw a
picture of you guys i filmed two
segments when i was there like i didn't
i was going for fun and then neil was
like all right i'll come with you i'm
like hold the camera follow me around
mic me up we're running the streets and
i filmed two segments the first segment
was
how to ball on a budget like what you
could do in new york i'm like i'm i
pulled a thousand bucks out of an atm
this is all the money i have for the
whole weekend let's see what kind of
trouble we get great idea and i went and
it was like central park free statual
liberty ferry 22 bucks like museums 17
bucks bike ride 12 but like
i didn't spend a thousand bucks at the
best time in new york i was running all
over the streets i didn't get stabbed i
didn't get raped i didn't get molested
great time kind of wish i got raped but
that's another story oh dear if there
was a you know hot chick or whatever or
maybe a trench did you learn nothing
from the conversation we just had
nothing in one ear out the other zero
like it's just unbelievable this is the
problem with uh with bad boys with edge
but then number two
i did a lot of interviews and i asked
people three questions
how expensive is it to live here in new
york how much is your rent and what do
you get for it
um i think like
32 billion dollars of taxpayer revenue
has left new york since the pandemic do
you think those people are coming back
and i got a wide array of answers
and just what do you love about new york
city so i really asked locals only so
the first segment was like touristy
stuff what you can do is geared for its
tourists and then i interviewed
dozens of locals
i got to tell you like the locals of new
york unless you're a billionaire
millionaire saving money on taxes new
yorkers are the best man they love new
york they're from new york they
represent new york they're basically
saying go go you want to come back we'll
take you back but don't forget what new
york is like the vibe of new york like
diversity culture electric amazing i
love new york city granted it is a
little bit dirty and granted it is crazy
expensive it's very dirty so if you
don't like garbage on the streets
or paying high rent new york's probably
not for you yeah but if you like being
able to go to any comedy show or
broadway show or amazing food or amazing
people or cultures or being able to walk
wherever you want
and do everything energy looks great how
did you feel about the energy because
florida right now is hot right
in many ways it's hot because it's very
hot here but it's also hot because a lot
of people came here and it's it's
feeling like the energy is very on here
how did you feel about the energy in new
york there did you feel like any of what
we talked about i've been back to since
i moved here so we may have different
opinions about it but did you feel like
any of the energy of like it feeling a
little depleted or a lot of people had
left or a little bit of the soul was was
not was missing well in the summers it's
fair to say especially on the weekends a
lot of the
uppity type people will go to the
hamptons right right so that's but
that's been every year they go to the
hamptons
if put how about this let me answer the
question directly if you would have told
me
that hey by the way this whole city
during covet lockdown
like was like a ghost town gotham city
type vibes
i would be like yeah i'm not sensing any
of that
i didn't get any of those vibes okay
like you'll see the content that i put
out i was up and down the streets
walking around having a good time
there's people in central park people
are going to place dinners are packed i
went to little italy for dinner great
time like
it didn't
feel as like
crazy desolate blue democrat horrible
homeless takeover
that you've heard about let me give you
one more um
story i've heard the same thing about la
and i did experience l.a because i went
with patrick
shout out to pbd i went with pat and
tigran in 2020 and we went to venice
specifically to see all the homelessness
and it was pervasive it was bad we went
back last month
and it was
so much better and i think we can all
agree if la was a [ __ ] show pat from la
vie iran he would call it out
we've talked about this in the podcast
he's like we had a great time venice was
nice yeah so i think
yes new york city la some of these you
know big blue metro metropolitan cities
definitely suffered during lockdowns in
covit
but
i hopefully think they've learned their
lesson and that you can't lock people
down yeah they didn't though but you're
more coming from a vaccine angle or what
angle i'm just toxic i'm coming from a
tax angle i'm coming from a mandate
angle i'm coming from a soft on crime
i'm right there with you
i just think i think these places
what i feel since going back to new york
um i've been back very briefly but what
i feel is that it's a that the tourists
have come back
i see that happening i see that energy i
i definitely see that some of the
restaurants are you know back in
business and they've all built things
outside yeah
exactly they had to be able to
stuff on the curve
exactly you couldn't go inside and some
of them are kind of cute what they do
yes except for the traffic that that
ensues as a result because now you've
got a whole bunch of parking in the
middle of the street so there's no
that's another whole chaotic thing down
the middle of the street on the side of
the street it's basically in the middle
of the street your car can you know
depending on the car you have you may or
may not fit down the middle but um
i i think the tourists came back but
everybody i know who left new york is
not going back
they're not going back and there's still
a whole bunch of people in new york that
are desperate to get out because i think
they're worried and i think that i think
it's different if you're single if
you're young
i think those people aren't concerned
about the same things as
parents are like i don't know that i
would have been so focused on the crime
and so focused on the mandates and so
focused on the bureaucracy if i didn't
have a child you know so i think that i
think that maybe the population may
change
and you may see an influx of people who
are in a different stage of life flock
into new york where they're not as
worried about finances you know a lot of
people go to new york and they live
six people in a little two-bedroom
apartment they can afford to do that and
they're like oh who cares you know when
you're single you have a lot more
flexibility more flexibility that's
great and younger because you're not you
don't have responsibility to another
human you know in most situations if you
if you don't make serious money in new
york city yeah whatever you want to call
qualify as serious money let's say 250
grand a year whatever
and you want to have kids you can't live
in new york city yeah that's right that
you can't do that you go to long island
you move to south florida like you kind
of get in and get out of there but
you're from new york i'm from new york
so okay and you were born in
70s i was born 79. born in brooklyn so
new york in the 70s and early 80s before
giuliani showed up that's what it looks
like no hole yeah hell hole no way is
that's not that oh it's pretty close
because let me tell you something if you
go if you're in the center i don't know
where you hung out when you were in new
york i was literally everywhere
literally battery park up to like upper
west side you go by the 10th and 11th
avenues if you go all the way west and
you go all the way to kitchener
yep if you go in hell's kitchen and you
go out
you go if you go chelsea's beers at
night it was nice chelsea piers isn't so
bad now i'm talking about you go in the
50s you go all the way what i'm what
giuliani did is basically and you can
love him you can hate him but the crime
areas became
less and they were smaller and now what
you have is those areas they're just
bleeding out so i have friends that live
on 11th avenue on 54th street that are
like i don't even it's a mess out here
at night so i don't know i mean listen
i'm glad to hear that some of the life
is i love that city that's my city i'm
glad to hear some of the life is back
but that place is going to have to
change when it comes to crime when it
comes to mandates when it comes to taxes
if they're going to incentivize people
like me to go but i mean i just have no
yeah well when they're losing people
like you and losing people with
microphones they're going to talk [ __ ]
about the city that they're from that
should be a trigger warning saying guys
we're not doing something right they
don't care but they should i know they
should care but i will say new york is a
very magical place and i only want the
best for new york city i love new york
city however i'm not moving there i'm
going to stay in miami yeah of course
not because you're not crazy
you want to keep your money adam i do
like every other sane person you want to
keep a cat if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here